there are several who suggested that FBR
was wrong to intervene back in the New
Deal they're fighting battles that I
thought were resolved a pretty long time
ago
the recession officially ended way back
in June of 2009 so why are so many still
out of work
government has been very busy trying to
fix the problem
bank bailout programs to avoid
foreclosed cash for clunkers auto
industry bailout economic stimulus taken
together this bold persistent
experimentation has brought our economy
back from the brink President Obama has
a lot in common with the original bold
persistent experimentation
Franklin Roosevelt was a charismatic
Democrat wrote in the making idle here
today he replaced an unpopular
Republican during the time of crisis
Roosevelt National Recovery Act has
brought both the pledge of million to
aid his program like Obama FDR
championed a slew of policies aimed at
getting people back to work I stand all
fall by my refusal to accept a permanent
army of unemployed today many credit FDR
with rescuing America from the Great
Depression but there's plenty wrong with
that view says UCLA economics professor
Lee Ohanian what's wrong with that view
is that private sector jobs didn't come
back under FDR Americans often forget
how long the Great Depression lasted
says Ohanian who specializes in economic
crisis unemployment stood at 17 percent
in 1939 a decade after the infamous
stock market crash the 1930s was much
worse than today but Ohanian sees some
parallels productivity is rising very
rapidly today in the 1930s the banking
system has largely been restored both
today in 1930s so the key puzzle for
both the 1930s and today is you know why
aren't private sector jobs being created
in a much more rapid rate uncertainty
may have something to do with it
uncertainty is an enemy of job creation
in a world with a lot of uncertainty
there's a sense to wait and see wait and
see what Washington's next experiment
will be we've been waiting for a year
this process started one year ago and
the last six months has been a monthly
what's going to happen today's the day
CEO to
Garneau has spent a year waiting for the
announcement of a new Federal Trade
Commission regulation his Paris press
obviously Garneau heads up nationwide
Support Services which employs about 250
people the company teaches financial
literacy and helps those who are in debt
but can't afford credit counseling and
don't want to give up and declare
bankruptcy it's going to dictate to us
how our business move for we garner
hopes to hire more employees but the new
regulation will determine that and you
know if if we stay in business the
future of her company depends on one
question that will be answered today
well the FTC forbid her from charging
fees until after a customer's debt is
settled I don't know of any business
that can go for two or three years
without actually getting any income
coming in we move into a conference room
and wait to hear the official
announcement from the FTC chairman and
Vice President Joe Biden so there's your
answer
but Garneau learns the news from a press
release issued just before the press
conference so it's basically a
rulemaking that is aimed at putting us
out of business that's what it says it's
what she feared most a fee ban is gonna
force more people into bankruptcy it is
going to affect our industry and putting
people out of work the United States
July but with the news already known the
official announcement is anticlimactic
this is part of the commitment President
Obama is making to the American people
Garneau is already thinking about
finding out what else is in the new
regulation we're about ready to start
sorting through and see what all this
means all 229 pages of it and this is
just one regulation a tiny one by
Washington standards
how will Obamacare end up affecting
companies for the 23 hundred page
financial overhaul what if taxes go up
so it's pretty difficult sometimes to
manage your business because you're
trying to manage forward and you're not
you have to look over your shoulder to
see if what's coming at you they're very
much as a sense of deja vu banthus
Depression era polls suggest that
business owners held back from hiring
because they were frightened by the New
Deal
and you may be surprised at who else
develops in second
one item that people don't really know
about is that FDR totally turned his
view about his New Deal and about the
effectiveness of the economic policies
that he put in place in the early 1930s
FDR experimented on the economy for
nearly two terms before private-sector
job growth started increasing a lot of
the increases we started to see in the
US economy that started around 39 40 41
or because some of these New Deal
policies were coming off but by that
time FDR's policies had already
prolonged the depression by 7 years
according to Ohanian x' research it was
Roosevelt's Antin market policies that
prevented private-sector job creation
and what about Obama's policies things
are still tough they just aren't as bad
as they could have been they could have
been a catastrophe we don't have the
parallel universe where we could run the
other experiment where we have the same
type of downturn but we don't do the
stimulus plan we don't some do some of
these other plans today unemployment has
remained above 9% for 17 months and
Counting just two more months at that
rate and it'll be the longest stretch of
severe unemployment since the Great
Depression people kind of say yeah but
unemployment still it 9.6 yes but it's
not 12 or 13 once unemployment finally
does improve will Obama receive credit
for rescuing America from the Great
Recession you gotta say or blame for
prolonging the crisis we didn't get much
in plumb recovery in 1930s we're not
getting much today few jobs but lots of
action time for action is now voters do
like action remember FDR won re-election
three times we'll see if the same
strategy works for President Obama in
the politicians of both parties who
favor bold persistent experimentation
for Reason TV
I'm Ted baliker